auf der Suche nach einer bezahlbaren
Wohnung Andrea Bach ist fast täglich
unterwegs in neus seit einem Jahr ohne
Chance für Menschen mit wenig Einkommen
ist momentan ganz schwierig also unter 8
€ pro Quadratmeter sich hier gar nichts
mehr und dadurch passt das gar nicht
mehr in den Rahmen den das Jobcenter mir
vorgibt Andrea Bach zeigt uns wie sie
lebt wohnt in einer
frauennotunterkunft hat nicht mal eine
Meldeadresse nach Abitur und Ausbildung
war sie Kinderkrankenschwester 21 Jahre
bis zum Burnout danach war sie
Altenpflegerin auf Teneriffa als sie
zurückkam war sie auf Bürgergeld
angewiesen und die Wohnungssuche
schwieriger denn je ich habe seit
letzten Herbst gemerkt dass eben durch
die Zuwanderung aus den Krisengebieten
sehr viel Konkurrenz da ist hab dann ein
Artikel gefunden in der Zeitung dass DAK
alten Wohnungen an Flüchtlinge vermietet
wurden und da war ich als
bürgergeldempfänger schon wahnsinnig
enttäuscht und auch irgendwo wütend weil
ich nicht mir erklären konnte warum ich
da keine Wohnung bekomme der Ökonom
Matthias Günther berät Kommunen er
bestätigt dass sich die Wohnungsnot
durch Zuwanderung verschärft hat in der
Summe kommen wir 2022 und 23 in Richtung
2 Millionen netto Zuwanderer und die
Bautätigkeit war im letzten Jahr bei
300.000 Wohnungen sie wird dies Jahr
vermutlich deutlich niedriger liegen das
heißt diese Bautätigkeit reicht
natürlich nicht aus um diese Zuwanderung
eben aufzufangen dabei hatte die
ampelregierung 400.000 neue Wohnungen
versprochen pro Jahr davon 100.000
Sozialwohnungen beim sozialen
Wohnungsbau muss man n nicht sagen um
100.000 Sozialwohnungen pro Jahr zu
schaffen da reicht das was die Ampel an
Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten ausgelobt hat
hinten und vorne nicht ein Bündnis aus
Mieterbund Baugewerkschaft und
sozialverbänd fordert von der
Bundesregierung 50 Milliarden Euro zur
Bekämpfung der
Wohnungskrise das Bundesbauministerium
rühmt sich mit der Zitat Rekordsumme von
18 Milliarden Euro bis
2027 für den sozialen Wohnungsbau zur
Konkurrenz zwischen Geringverdienern und
Flüchtlingen auf dem Wohnungsmarkt teilt
das Bauministerium auf frontalanfrage
mit Zitat die Bundesregierung
unterstützt Menschen in dieser
schwierigen Lage über den SGB zug also
Bürgergeld oder durch das Wohngeld und
der Kreis der Anspruchsberechtigten
wurde
verdreifacht ein schönes Gesetz so haben
jetzt 11 Millionen Haushalte Anspruch
auf eine Sozialwohnung die hässliche
Realität es gibt nur eine Millionen
Sozialwohnungen Köln Familie niestreu
mit ihren drei Kindern zu Besuch bei der
Oma auch sie haben einen
Wohnberechtigungsschein bei Ihrer
Wohnungssuche hat der bisher nichts
genutzt Wohnung finden sie seit Jahren
nicht ihre 86 quadr Wohnung ist viel zu
klein und sogar
gesundheitsschädlich denn ihre Wohnung
ist feucht seit Jahren Schimmelbefall
sogar echte Pilze sprießen aus Wand und
Boden ärzte warnen vor den
Gesundheitsrisiken die Kinder leiden an
Atemwegserkrankungen Atteste liegen dem
Vermieter von novia vor sie brauchen
dringend eine neue Wohnung keiner
kümmert sich nein wir werden da im Stich
gelassen ja was sagen sie
dazu werden immer vertröstet halt dass
es keine gibt
vonovia antwortet ausweichend beginnt
aber nach der frontalanfrage mit der
Wohnungssanierung doch das Problem
bleibt für eine größere Wohnung reicht
das Geld nicht obwohl beide arbeiten er
als Maschinenführer sie als Kassiererin
im
Supermarkt wie ist Ihr
Budget eigentlich 1200 aber wir haben
schon hochgestuft auf 1500 mehr geht
nicht und sie finden nichts in Köln
ja hinzu kommt mit ihrem Maximalbudget
konkurriert die junge Familie mit der
Stadt Köln die auch Wohnungen sucht für
Flüchtlinge für einen fünf
personersenhaushalt wie die niestreus
zahlt die Stadt bis zu € kalt dazu
Nebenkosten von rund 400 € auch die
Aussicht der nestreus auf eine
Sozialwohnung ist durch die
flüchtlingskrise noch geringer geworden
denn die Kölner Wohnungsgesellschaft Gag
schreibt uns Zitat kurz nach Beginn des
Krieges gegen die Ukraine wurde
entschieden 20% des verfügbaren
lehrstands für ukrainische geflüchtete
zur Verfügung zu
stellen von ihren 45000 Wohnungen kann
die Kölner Wohnungsgesellschaft etwa
1000 neu vermieten pro Jahr trotzdem
auch hier bisher keine Chance für die
niestreus denn die GAG teilt auf Anfrage
weiter mit Zitat es gibt
bedauerlicherweise neben der Familie
niestreu viele Hilfebedürftige Familien
die derzeit in nicht zumutbaren
Wohnverhältnissen Leben und daher auf
die Hilfe der Gag ebenso oder gar mehr
angewiesen sind als die Familie niestreu
Übach Palenberg bei Aachen der Stad sind
sprchen ihrer Größe von 20.000
Einwohnern bisher 360 Flüchtlinge vom
Land zugewiesen worden weil die
Asylunterkunft nicht mehr reicht hat die
Stadt schon 46 Wohnungen anmieten müssen
das bereitet Bürgermeister Oliver Walter
sorgen wir versuchen unsere Flüchtlinge
dezentral unterzubringen damit wir keine
Ghettobildung haben das heißt aber für
uns weil wir nicht wissen wer wann wo
wie kommt müssen wir immer Wohnung
vorhalten das heißt wir mieten quasi den
Wohnungsmarkt Markt in üach Palmberg
leer mit der Folge dass die Leute die
etwas schwächer betucht sind
Schwierigkeiten haben hier eine Wohnung
zu finden für den cduann sind die
Grenzen erreicht bis hin zu dem Thema
dass dann auch die Flüchtlinge nicht
mehr akzeptiert werden weil sie einfach
eine Belastung für die Bevölkerung
darstellen Münsterland hier hat die
Stadt Eninger Loh 100 Wohnungen gemietet
für Flüchtlinge darüber hinaus sind in
dieser Immobilie 80 Schutzsuchende aus
der Ukraine untergebracht eigentlich
sollte das Haus kommendes Jahr
abgerissen werden wegen Baufälligkeit
vielleicht früher fürchten Bürgermeister
Berthold Lülf und sozialdezendent Ralf
Schindler ich weiß es nicht müssen wir
sehen vor allen kommt jetzt die kalte
Jahreszeit und das die marode Heizung da
drin das ist richtig bin ich ja mal
gespannt wie das wie das dann läuft wenn
die Heizung kaputt geht ist die große
Unbekannte an der Stelle ja zurück am
Rathaus es stehen wieder Flüchtlinge vor
der Tür eine Gruppe aus dem
afrikanischen Burundi gerade angekommen
aus der Erstaufnahme müssen auch sie
untergebracht
werden eine flächendeckende
nightdiskussion soweit sind wir nicht
ich denke aber schon wenn wir wenn wir
als Kommune dieser Herausforderung nicht
begegnen dann wird das so passieren das
ist so zumindest meine große Sorge was
erwarten Sie daavon Land und Bund aus
meiner Sicht
politisch sicherlich sehr kontrovers zu
beurteilen aber eine eine klare Regelung
des Zuzuges vielleicht sogar eine
Begrenzung des
Zuzuges die Kommunen sind am Anschlag
wir fragen nach bei der NRW
Landesregierung schriftlich heißt es
Zitat individuelle Lösungen wie etwa
Zuwanderungsstopp sein für einzelne
Städte und Gemeinden möglich und weiter
beim Ausbau der landeskapazitäten setzen
wir auf die Kooperation mit den Kommunen
und die Akzeptanz vor Ort der Opposition
im Landtag reicht das nicht die
flüchtlingsunterbringung in
Nordrhein-Westfalen ist völlig chaotisch
das Problem ist dass es mindestens 70
000 Plätze des Landes geben müsste zur
Unterbringung von geflüchteten derzeit
haben wir nicht einmal die Hälfte die
Kommunen leisten hier wirklich
herausragendes und sind trotzdem
mittlerweile am Rande der Überforderung
und das führt unterm Strich natürlich
dazu dass auch die Akzeptanz in der
Bevölkerung deutlich leidet wenn die
vonkurenzsituation entsteht Akzeptanz
vor Ort darum geht es auch in der
Kleinstadt bei Münster sie hat 110
Wohnungen für geflüchtete gemietet und
baut gerade 100 neue Sozialwohnungen das
Bund und Land unterstützen findet der
Bürgermeister gut trotzdem bleiben
Fragen wenn ich ein Programm habe das
mir nur Wohnraum fördert wenn ich dort
geflüchtete aus der Ukraine unterbringe
dann schafft das soziale Härten dann
schafft das auch
Verwerfungen diese Sporthalle inelgte
auch schon Flüchtlingsunterkunft Kosten
dafür rund 2 Millionen Euro pro Jahr auf
denen die Stadt sitzen bleibt hinzu
kommt Vereine und Schulsport müssen
kürzer treten gibt's Hinweise dass die
Akzeptanz nachlässt die Akzeptanz ist
noch sehr sehr hoch aber ich gebe Ihnen
Recht der Ton wird etwas rauer weder
Familie niestreu noch Andrea Bach haben
bisher eine bezahlbare Wohnung gefunden
auch sie fordern Hilfe ein wollen nicht
vergessen werden in diesen
Krisenzeiten